we have new information this morning
about a u.s. Navy veteran who is
detained in Iran
Michael White's family says he's been
held captive in the country since last
summer and it echos the case of our
Roxana Saberi
in 2009 before joining CBS News she was
imprisoned in Iran on a false charge of
spying for the CIA Roxana was released
after a hundred days she has spoken with
White's mother and joins us now from
London Roxana I am sure White's mother
of all people could really have heard
from you and appreciated that
conversation that you had tell us about
what she said well good morning and I
hope she appreciated it was a good
conversation for me as well
jo-ann White says she is begging Iran to
free her son she also told me she wants
the Trump administration to speak with
the Iranian authorities to secure his
release iran's Foreign Ministry
spokesman confirmed Wednesday that Iran
arrested Michael White quote some time
ago he added that white is being
investigated though he didn't say for
what White's mother says her son had
traveled to Iran three times to visit an
Iranian woman he had met online but the
46 year old didn't return from his trip
in July she says it wasn't until about
three weeks ago that the State
Department told her he was detained at
about the same time a former inmate who
says he met white in prison broke the
news of White's detention on Twitter
ivar Farhadi told me white was suffering
psychologically and was being held with
dangerous criminals the State Department
has not commented on any ongoing efforts
to secure White's release dianna and as
you mentioned this hits home close to
you for because of the many reasons that
you were held there for a hundred days
you were held at a different prison but
based on your experience there what
could he be going through right now
there is a pattern typically your first
put in solitary confinement when you're
cut off from the outside world you don't
get any phone calls you don't have
access to an attorney
which is the experience that White had
according to the former inmate who met
him in prison you also undergo intense
interrogations in my case I was
blindfolded facing a wall and pressured
to make a false confession prisoners
also report being tortured whether it's
physical or psychological the hardest
part from
was to be in solitary confinement
because you have no one to talk to
except herself and you have nothing to
do except think and usually what you
think about is how worried your family
is about you especially when they don't
know where you are and they could even
think you're dead which all makes you a
lot more vulnerable to the pressures of
prison Roxana this is very chilling just
hearing you talk about this and I know
we got to go but why did they think you
were spy to begin with you know to this
day I'm not certain I do know that it is
a fairly common accusation that the
Iranian authorities make against dual
nationals Iranian Americans as well as
Americans and they often fabricate
evidence and put you under pressure as I
said to make false confessions and
without an attorney it's very hard to
defend yourself
Roxana thank you extraordinary insight
on what Michael White and his family are
going through thank you so much